mit zwei diaz 2 dezember sollte was geht
ab es gilt war damit wohl treu es ist
glaube ich folge nummer
[Musik]
unser ziel ist heute ich bin übrigens
schon längst drauf ich bin jetzt auch
drauf ich brauche schon noch recht aus
eisen ab was er wo bin ich
das geht du bist nicht auf dem server
definitiver ich bin ich bin ich habe oft
warum war ich habe drei server betreten
also nicht hingekriegt so john waters
notiert bist du drauf jetzt bist du
drauf bei mir nicht war einfach auf dem
falschen server wieso das denn
vielleicht war es zu heiß oder komme
oder irgendwie so ich war auf jeden fall
in dem haus du bist nun verwundbar ach
du scheiße
ok weißt du ich habe letzte nacht
geträumt von war ohne wahrheit simone
witz wirklich ich habe davon geträumt
von dieser schlucht hier in der wir
gerade sind und da habe ich geträumt
dass wir das dass ich irgendwo runter
gelaufen bin und dann diamant und
übersehen habe und in den kommentaren so
geschlemmt wurde reese diamant alter
es war so krank wie gut also wir haben
schon gesagt was unser ziel für die
heutige folge diamanten werden ein ganz
neues und ich schwimme mit dem
wasserfall hoch und es wäre halt auch
hammer wenn irgendwie ich weiß nicht
also ich wäre halt hammer wenn irgendwie
so keine ahnung noch ein paar kisten
finden irgend so eine schüssel
wie komme ich denn jetzt hier hoch keine
ahnung gerade hatte ich ganz sicher
warum das hier ist noch ein bisschen
reisen gerade sich also wirklich das
ganze mit dem damit uns dann
letztendlich nachher feuerzeuge machen
können den ganzen stoff und dann auch
noch links holen halt irgendwie wenn es
klar geht irgendwie keine ahnung
diamanten wenn man so findet dafür sind
wir aber definitiv nicht auf der
passenden höhe ausschaut aber doch
geklappt er definitiv nicht auf der
passenden höhe
aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch keinen
bock zu strip meinen übrigens ich muss
noch mal eine ganz kurze sache hier
sagen weil das so viel unter die videos
geschrieben wird freunde es ist kein
mann bekommt keinen strike das schmeckt
was gerade drin habe ist das richtige
texture pack alle schreiben wir in die
scheiß kommentare ok dürfte dritte
street schon wieder das budget action
pack mich fakt das so ab dass alle
meinen sie kennen die regeln besser als
die tatsächlichen waro teilnehmer das
ist so alle sind so besserwisserischen
immer den kommentaren und meinen sie
wüssten welchen strike man hat und wie
viele und was dann passiert nein man
darf ist ist das richtige station welche
ich zeigt sich auch nochmal resource
packs zwecks habe ich nicht drin sondern
ich habe war drin und zwar seht ihr doch
sogar schon an den blöcken hier das ist
gar nichts weg sondern facebook und man
darf halt wie verändern und diese
gegenstände wie beispielsweise ein
schwert oder so weil ich mag facebook
gar nicht
deswegen habe ich die ganzen anderen
sachen von zwecks reingenommen so dass
jetzt zwar erst mal kurz zu dieser
debatte
und ich wollte noch irgendwas ansprechen
bezüglich fahrer bezogen aber das habe
ich gerade vergessen
ich schau mal hier hinten da beim wasser
völlig doch da warst du schon jetzt geht
die hürde bei der wir können uns jetzt
rein theoretisch sogar mal ein bisschen
trennen also ich denke das wird jetzt
nicht so schlimm sein hat mich sowieso
schon ein bisschen getrennt von mir
haben sie zu tun haben will
ich laufe aber irgendwie die schächte
gedanken wir müssen weiter nachrichten
nicht ja ist die frage entweder laufen
wir weiter in dieser komischen höhle
oder begraben und hat uns aber aufgraben
habe ich eigentlich so lustig so wir
verloren haben könnten ja dann macht ja
meist man einmal und dann mit ein
bisschen lover mitnehmen oder so ich
sehe den namen neuer lover verhältnissen
creeper gut ich habe den raum gefunden
so einen raum keine ahnung wie man
diesen raum nennt ja ich hab leider
getötet das ist sonst bauraum keine
ahnung wie nennt man das ich habe heute
überhaupt keine ahnung das sind zu räume
wurden hat alle
hobsbawm hier ist die kiste mit zwei
diaz 2 die als zwei diaz in der kiste
gefunden mein gott oh mein gott
ok ja ich finde dann ich habe gerade
einen namen irgendwo gesehen
die ersten die us-liga unseren namen
hier siehst du mein name ich bin über
die irgendwo ich brate jetzt mal ein
bisschen fleisch hier siehst du meinen
namen hier warte ich komm mal eben zu
dir
diese männer haben ich gucke nicht ich
bin gerade hier im zaubern ja dann über
die ich grad grad ein weg runter ja ok
ok kommen am besten hier gleich lang
okay okay jetzt drauf fieldings so viel
eisen ist er auch überall ja deswegen
also es ist gerade hier eigentlich ein
ganz schilliger spot gold sollte genau
auf her wollte ich habe jetzt nicht so
viel
wir waren einmal ich glaube so ich bin
kannst du mir auch welche machen ja ich
wollte ja auch zu euch jetzt mal ein
paar alte möchte ich einfach nicht
benötige
daraus hätte da schon darf machen fallen
ich habe auch letztens gelesen irgendwo
ich hätte zuckerrohr fallen gelassen
was okay das wäre echt ärgerlich ein
bisschen aber mein gott ist das auch
nicht so schlimm ich weiß auch gar nicht
wollen wir aus den eimern direkt links
machen aus den diamanten direkt hier
irgendwann spinnens bonner jetzt
definitiv irgendwann spinnens bonner da
ist ein spinner wie viele heime brauchst
du kann man albers decken nur leere
eimer auf den spitzensport ins kalte
wasser ob man was denken kann einmal
kannst du nicht stecken nur leere glaube
ich oder ich ja ich meine schon ja jetzt
geht am besten mit wieder da hinten hin
weil da das richtig viel versprechend
aus bitte sowie ihr weit wie möglich
weil wir jetzt echt mal etwas schaffen
müssen ich bin bei dir nur damit wollte
er nur wollte nur das eisen beraten
damit du einmal haben kannst ach so ja
das können auch denke ich nachher noch
machen nur da jetzt was geiles gefunden
haben 2 die as alter okay ich laufe
durch was sich aufnehmen kann nämlich
mit ich schmeiße mal eben so ein paar
sachen recht ich brauche diese ganzen
cobblestone es ist echt viel zu viel
dirty kies nach wir wollten auch zeugen
ja ich habe aber jetzt auch gerade kein
egal kommen das gamescom und auch hinter
dir kommen die medikamente mit kommen
hier mit lang ging es hier und mir hier
ging es hier ging es nicht langweilig
allerdings hier lang
[Musik]
ich mach mal eben was sein wasser
wo bist du jetzt hingegangen dies meinen
namen nicht ich bin hier ja kommen da
lang und jetzt wieder hier die treppe
hoch hier ja ich weiß nicht ganz genau
wo ich langweilig glaube ich war hier
lange kommt so hier oder hier ist auch
wieder nicht ausgeleuchtet
das ist so wie ich aussah das ist echt
hier ist jedes zweite passt auf passaus
okay natürlich die kriege ich nur ist
noch wann was ist mein ok hab leider
meist kommt hier das hier war dass ich
habe hier sollen gefunden ist auch noch
so viel
und hier war diese kiste und hier sind
ja schon rails und brad drin
jetzt könnte man heiraten mit dem blumen
ja irgendwer deutschen hat dieser raum
ihre ganzen brauner profis im projekt
würden jetzt bestimmt wissen ja dass ist
das und datenblatt stehen und der und
der mob aber abgebaut erste neue
schlucht um eine neue schlacht um einmal
davon gehört jetzt einfach eine neue
schlucht weiter hier ist das ist einfach
viel zu geil dass wir so ein ding
gefunden haben hier sind giftige spinnen
die sind giftige spinnen hier muss man
ein bisschen aufpassen rät wenn hier bei
der auch das bei mir also neben der ein
bisschen ja ich nehme jetzt auch noch
mal das ganze alten hiermit wir müssen
die wir werden echt produktiver das
finde ich richtig stark vom lauf ich
weiß nicht wie in die schluchten geben
soll das ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen zu riskant ich laufe durch
diese anderen gegen hier ein bisschen
durch und rennt die schlucht eigentlich
schon interessant weil ich bock auf mehr
dialog
ja ich auch aber ich glaub die die wir
sind immer noch zu hoch um diamanten zu
finden
deswegen schaue ich halt immer noch nach
ob wir noch mehr kisten finden
durch wen ich da hinten gerade wieder
eine und da hab ich schon geöffnet
ja ich meine das war die da hinten die
schulleiter hier egal einfach alles
reisen mitnehmen alles mitnehmen gott
des meeres mehr noch wir haben desto
besser
in der tat sind wir machen dann einfach
so einen kleinen markt auch ja das ist
die beste die ich schon geöffnet hatte
wenn die leute irgendwas brauchen dann
kommen sie zu uns genau wie kämpfen
nicht mit uns wird schweden altmann wir
mit ihren ja man das ist unsere aufgabe
in diesem projekt kirche ist auch nichts
mehr grabmal und zu bitte ein bisschen
gremmel ab damit wir eventuell den ein
oder anderen cent bekommen für ein
feuerzeug ich habe sechs linz
du hast sechs plänen zur perfekt denn
sein team passt das soll die flinte erst
licht gerade dann wahrscheinlich schon
jetzt auch überall hin wo ich schon
lange gelaufen bin ich lasse alle ich
habe die kiste
wahrscheinlich ist dies eine fackel habe
ehrlich nicht ich lasse ich jetzt mal
sind eisen liegen hier alle was lerne
unnötig eigentlich haben genug fleisch
erst mal aber nimm einfach mal mit drin
gelassen eisen kann ich auch gar nicht
mit dem weizen haben wir brauchen wir
fahren wo es ging direkt holen wir auch
ich kann ihnen hier gefällt brauchen
auch nicht letzten körner
ich hab irgendwann mal etwas anbauen
glaube ich nicht denke ich auch eher
weniger ok ich finde jetzt hin aber auch
nix mehr gerade dauer der dungeon ja das
ist schon krass was wir hier alles zu
entdecken
deswegen da hab ich halt mehr bock drauf
als einfach nur mich runter zu graben
da finde ich lieber weniger diamanten
aber hab ich was sage ich mal
anstatt dann da also erstes licht mich
so thomas ersetzen irgendwo natürlich
waren wir schon
was meinst du wo waren wir schon sind
irgendwie immer gänge und dann ist der
licht und dann wieder doch kein licht
mehr so ok ich also nicht möglich weil
die leute sind relativ weit oben dann
denke ich auch ich laufe einfach noch
mal selbst ein bisschen rum weil ich
finde ja auch immer wieder gänge und
dann waren wir aber irgendwie auch schon
und dann ist er doch wieder licht so wie
du hast ja aber richtig viele items
darin aber keine diamanten
hier sind 5 6 gold 4 kohle vier
lapislazuli und eisen und auch minuten
zusammen ich packe ich jetzt einmal auch
einen krieger gesehen
ich packte jetzt mal so ein paar sachen
rein wie cobblestone und zu was rotten
flesh brauchen wir und ich da hat da
gesehen dass ich auch im privaten gerne
dass ich nicht immer nur ein projekt
einfach nur mitlaufen allocation gute
kommt so hier hinten geht er heute ist
ich bin jetzt wieder bei diesem rosen
raum ja ich sehe den namen auch gerade
wo gehen wir wollen wir die schlucht
bahrain ist ein krieg oder passt einfach
in die schlucht okay da kann man auch
mal was man einfach weiter runter so
auch hier ist dieser weg wieder wo wir
waren ja welche richtung war die
schlucht weiß nicht was die hier
vielleicht
[Musik]
hier rum hier ist hier waren wir dass
die stoffe schon war dann wieder zurück
also ich bin dabei oder man verliert so
die orientierung
was heißt zurück und wieder zurück in
den raum und ich meine von da weiß ich
wo die schlucht ist wo ist er rosenheim
ich noch hier wo bist du so willst du
musst dir deinen namen nicht mehr wieder
natürlich amtlich gespielt verstärkt
oder also bis jetzt unter mir ja ich
besuche dort selber diese schlucht
hier ist ein gang wo wir noch nicht drin
waren kiste gefunden vier brot sechs
redstone ich will eigentlich unten hier
hab ich hallo hallo hier ist der rosenau
hier ist der roten rosen rosen rosen der
zombie im vorteil wir haben auch nicht
mehr so lange auf nämlich bald hier ist
noch dunkel die sind mehr zur miss das
wasser fließt das wasser kann ich habe
auch komplett neue gänge geht verbinden
ich bin bei der schlucht ja ich hab mir
grad konstant meine gegner gefunden
ja da bin ich quasi ja okay wir leben
auf mich ein bisschen warum ich meine
hier unten ist ja gar kein anderes team
das heißt wir können ja hier sind auf
einer höhe quasi klavier sind spinnen
ich bin ein kämpfer
das oft genug sagen dann glaube ich dass
irgendwann alles aus ja wenn du da warst
ich möchte alles aus ihr sind
verzaubertes buch hätte gerne noch mehr
ehrlich was ist darauf verbrennung zwei
schutz 3 hier ist wieder nur melonen
samen in der kirche aber nochmal machen
brauchen wir goldbarren
das ist auf jeden fall wenn der
verbrennung drauf ist und so freunde
schreibt man bitte die kommentare wo wir
das drauf verzaubern können weil ich hab
keine ahnung von ja dass wir nicht
ich habe noch weniger ahnung hast du
auch werden gekickt wird gekickt
erstmalig muss noch länger über den
solche wo bist du ja ich sehe da einen
namen aber da ich dir dann versucht man
noch zu dir zu kommen weil sie nehmen
mir okay wir haben
diamanten gefunden das war ganz geil
aber das war noch die einzigen
verwandten zwei stück kann man sich
einen schwer draus machen aber ich weiß
nicht inwiefern sich ein schwert lohnt
viele meinen ja auch immer dass ich mehr
desto besser sind oder so schreibt es
das meine kommentare auch wo wir dein
buch drauf verzaubern können sagt man
mal was da drauf ist verbrennung zwei
schutz drei leute ja ich meine das ist
doch einfach wenn wir das auf einem
brustpanzer machen
der gegner bringt brennt wenn er und
schlägt weil sie da und schutz 3 ist ja
auch gar nicht so schlecht ja
schutzbereich eigentlich auch ganz neu
ist deswegen freunde wie du bist jetzt
auch gepflegt ja ich bin runter okay
wenn es euch gefallen dann wollen wir
uns bei der bewertung freuen wir sehen
uns morgen ein paar wiesen 7 wieder
vorbei ist eine beschreibung